someone apologies for absence we have
apologies for daniel fd are there any
other apologies please
no
item two substitute members
we have councillor mrs daniel belton is
substituting for councillor
daniel fd
non-members attending
there isn't any
i just want a clarification i've got
welcome to gary myers
right okay we'll scrub that then
um
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the fourth uh on the second of
august
members for the first item 63 to 65 spa
road 21 stroke 01 007 stroke full
the following minute on the resulting
vote has been recorded incorrectly
and there was no mention of the
chairman's casting vote
i would like would therefore like to
move a motion as without notice to amend
the minutes as follows
have i got a second to please
thank you mr nathan
a motion uh moved by councillor
mrs c mason and secondly by councillors
to refuse the application on the grounds
of the proposed building being
dominant with bulk mass height flat
roofs dormers out of keeping with the
street scene an insufficiently high
standard of design was lost on a show of
hands by the chairman's casting vote
against the motion
and four members voted in favor of the
motion
five against including the chairman's
casting vote and one abstained
no counsellor eve's counselor mrs mason
councilman mr stanley wished to have
been it to be noted that they had voted
in favor of the motion
can i please have a second uh
thank you council stanley
uh that motion has been carried thank
you very much
item five to receive declarations of
interest
councillor williams
thank you um yeah item seven um
nonparticularly interesting
due to the fact that i'm a award
counsellor for that area and also
a member of rockford parish council
thank you very much thank you
agenda items six
twenty one stroke
zero one one three four stroke
o u t
two seven o eastwood row rayleigh
okay
katie fat
katie valla will present the officer's
report thank you katie
thank you chairman
this application is for the development
of 65 residential dwellings and a care
home on the application site 35 of the
dwellings would be affordable homes and
30 would be lifetime times access is the
only reserve matter for consideration at
the outline stage and the demolition of
270 eastwood road would be required to
accommodate this the access was provided
from eastwood road
as can be seen from the location plan
the application site is located to the
south of eastwood road and to the east
to south view
close the site extends backwards towards
the a127 but does not project up to the
highway it is otherwise surrounded by
land which appears to be primarily used
for agricultural and light industrial
purposes
the site is commonly allocated as
greenbelt and serves as a domestic
nursery the site has been put forward as
part of the call for sites but the new
local plan is still within its early
stages and is therefore not known
whether the site would be allocated for
residential development to go to plan
two thanks
an indicative layout and elevations plan
have been provided for the proposal
these are indicative only as layout
scale and appearance are reserved
matters and not for determination these
plans have been provided to demonstrate
how the quantum and type of development
could feasibly be accommodated on the
site
the application was originally brought
in front of members at development
committee in may the application had
initially been recommended for refusal
on five grounds relating to greenbelt
the absence of a noise survey to assess
the impact upon residential amenity
insufficient information to assess the
surface water impact insufficient
information to assess the impact on air
quality and insufficient information to
assess the impact of the access upon the
tpo oak tree
this application was deferred from the
committee following the applicant's
request to provide additional
information relating to the original
recommended reasons for refusal
the primary considerations in the
determination of this outline planning
application are the prince of the
development pros within its allocation
on the green belt proposed access
arrangements with the acceptability
including number of vehicles on the
highway network flood risk and drainage
ecological and environmental
considerations and other matters
including affordable housing residential
amenity and air
quality please
so firstly looking at the impact on the
green belt it is considered that the
proposed development would not meet the
exceptions outlined within paragraph 149
of the mppf and therefore would be
considered as inappropriate development
within the greenbelt given this the
development would need to amount to a
very special circumstance in order to
justify the harm to the green belt
the applicant has outlined within their
submission that they believe the need
for specialist accommodation for older
people within the district to outweigh
the identified inappropriateness of the
development it is acknowledged that both
local and national policies identify the
need for older people housing however it
is considered that there are other sites
within the district which would be able
to accommodate a similar type of
development without the harm to the
greenbelt and this is therefore not
considered to amount to a very special
circumstance
in addition the council's policy team
are clear that the number of affordable
homes that would be delivered by the
site can be accommodated within areas
outside of the green belt by way of
allocated sites which have been recently
granted planning permission or are in
the process of being delivered
there are considered to be no other very
special circumstances that would
outweigh the harm to the greenbelt and
on this basis officers consider the
proposal to be contrary to the mppf
in terms of the impact on the highway
access is not a matter of reserve and is
for consideration at the outline stage
the proposal involves the demolition of
270 eastwood road to provide access to
the site the plan on the screen depicts
the host site access with 2.4 metres by
43 metre visibility space in accordance
with the 30 mile per hour speed limit as
recommended in manual for streets
the highway authority have confirmed
that the visibility displays would not
interfere with the parking lay-by to the
west whilst there is an existing bus
stop outside of 270 eastwood road this
would be relocated outside the 20254
eastwood road which is to the west of
the lay-by that serves a parking area to
the dwellings on the southern side of
eastwood road by just pointing this out
on the screen
so
just without pointing up on
the this is the last group of dwellings
here that you can see on the screen and
below that is 254 so you can see the
lay-by ends here and so the bus stop
would be moved to the
further west so down here
the local highway authority have been
consulted on the application and raised
no objection to the application subject
to a number of recommended conditions
therefore the principle of the access
proposed is considered by officers as
acceptable
whilst this principle in this location
is accepted consideration must be had to
the impact upon neighbouring
properties the access would be located
between 268 a and 272 eastwood road and
would run along the rear gardens of the
properties along the eastern end of
south view close
the proposed development would require
vehicular access for visitors staff and
residents which would have a material
impact upon the adjoining neighbours
most significantly 272 eastwood road
which is adjoined by the residential
property of 270 eastwood road
no noise survey has been provided with
the application to enable officers to
adequately consider the impact of the
noise from the vehicles along this axis
upon neighbouring properties whilst the
application had been deferred to allow
for a noise survey to be completed no
one no noise survey was submitted
the environmental health officer was
consulted on the application and
suggested conditions to overcome these
however officers were not satisfied that
these met the relevant tests and the
potential impact of noise upon resident
humanity was still a concern contrary to
policy dn1 and paragraph 185a of the
mppf
if you could go to the flood risk
assessment thanks
the application site is located in flood
zones one two and three and so you can
see on the screen the blood zone two and
three mostly goes along the stream that
runs through the middle of the site and
then flood zones one are more to the
south and north pockets of it
the residential development would be
entirely located in flood zone one with
only the centre of the site falling
within flood zones two and three
the residential development is
considered to be located within areas at
lowest risk of flooding
and the development would pass the
sequential and exceptions test as a
result a bridge would be constructed as
part of the development which would
provide access over the central stream
and to the southern part of the site
hydraulic modelling of the bridge would
be required at the reserve matter stage
to inform the design the ea are content
with the information provided with
regards to the bridge and consider it to
provide a safe means of access and
egress to properties in the southern
extent
no issues are therefore raised with
regard to flood risk from fluvial
sources
go to page 40. thanks
the existing site is for the most part
made up by greenfield and the proposed
development would introduce 1.48
hectares of hard standing the increased
hardstanding would result in an increase
of surface water runoff and volumes and
therefore the surface water discharge
would need to be controlled an amended
flood risk assessment and drain strategy
have been submitted with the application
following initial objection raised to
the potential impact so the plan on the
screen just depicts the areas that are
at low and medium high risk of surface
water flooding currently so you can see
that that mostly is concentrated around
the stream and then a little bit tailing
up towards eastwood road but for the
most part it is within a low risk but
just because of the scale of the
development there were concerns about
the potential for surface water runoff
if you go to appendix eye please
so the applicant did then submit this
revised drainage strategy which included
an indicative
um
surface water plan so the drainage
strategy has detailed that an
attenuation storage would be required
which would be provided in the form of a
below ground attenuation tax for the
lifetime homes and within the eastern
aspect of the affordable homes and there
would be spaces for an attenuation pond
or basin so if you can see
that the attenuation point is
here and then under the
lifetime homes which i think here there
would be the attenuation tanks
in light of the submitted information
the lead local flood authority has
raised no objection to the application
subject to the imposition of conditions
where the application recommended for
approval
um if you could go back to plan three
please thanks
there are a number of trees are subject
to tpo within the site and are joining
the site the council's arbor cultural
officer is content that sufficient
distance between the root protection
areas of the tree within the eastern
aspect tree belt central built along the
east along the stream southern aspect
tree belt and western aspect retrieval
and the proposed development could be
maintained however it is unclear from
the submitted information whether the
tpo tpo oak tree located on eastwood
road could be retained by the proposal
further information was submitted by the
applicant and this was sent to the
council's armed officer who outlined
that whilst the access was clearly set
out there is still no uncommon there is
still no accompanying method statement
with regard to the depth of the
excavation requires for the footway and
highway or any likely services
there is also no detail on how this how
best this can be achieved without
compromising the health of the tree and
requiring its removal to the detriment
of visual amenti along eastwood road the
potential impact of the access upon the
oak tree is contrary to policy dm-25 and
the aims of the mppf
policy dm29 advises that all major
developments are required to submit an
air quality assessment with their
application to determine the potential
cumulative impact for additional
transport movements on potentially
significant road junctions
following the deferment of the
application from the may committee an
air quality assessment has been
submitted and this has been addressed in
the addendum the council's environmental
health officer has been consulted in the
application and upon review of the
submitted information raises no
objection concluding that the
development would not cause any new
exceedances of the air quality
objectives the application is
recommended for refusal chairman on the
on three grounds of refusal as noted
within the updated officers report and
addendum thank you
thank you very much we have no um public
speakers for this item
the award member
here tonight is uh councillor bob milne
uh would you like to speak on this
councillor milne
and you have five minutes thank you
yeah we'll do um
we've got to do the wall councillors
first council
yeah good evening um yeah from our uh
point of view
i would i know that there's been no
objections because of the plan to deal
with flooding
but quite frankly knowing that area and
knowing what's downwind of it when
you've got surface water runoff you get
ahead really heavy rain
this site could cause quite a lot of
problems and i quite agree with
the the observations about the harm to
the green belt because we have got other
sites there's the cherry orchard site
and others and that they're listed some
of them listed in this paper
so from that point of view
from my point of view i'm listening to
the arguments i support the conclusion
that
we should refuse
thank you
you chairman um before i
say what i want to say i just if i could
ask a question of the officer please
you made a comment on eastwood road i
know that access you said was not part
of the uh
issue here but i have a concern if you
could answer it for me
the bus stop for the number 22
sits as we look at that just above or to
the east of the in
the intended
entry
and you're talking about moving it south
past that but that would then take it
past clarence road
which would then
not i the the bus number 22 would not be
able to turn right which it doesn't
currently
to go down clarence road
so that would immediately remove a bus
stop for the people in that area and
it's an amenity that i'm concerned about
because there will be no bus stop
so though no one could get a 22. so if
they're coming from the hospital along
eastwood road they would have to park in
a bus stop probably another 100 meters
one way or past it the other way
yes sorry that is um not rdc's issue
would be no that will be unfortunately
for your question essex highways right
they are the ones who will um do it so
if we've got any issues there we'll have
to go back and speak to we'll have to
ask
rdc our officers just discussed that but
we can't discuss that here at the moment
i understand that i'm asking the officer
that could be raised in is as an issue
because i'm concerned about that
particular issue on this particular
program now if i get to my point if i
may
thank you i think you know where i'm
going with that one but so i'm concerned
with the bus stop but the other thing of
course is that um
i i'm sure every member of this this uh
committee has had a number of uh emails
from those that are making application
in this case
and i want to refer first of all to
comments made and i agree that this is
part of the mppf you know this is a
green belt and it's part of our local
plan et cetera et cetera and the
i thought it was quite arrogant when
there was a comment made in one of the
letters that are the emails to say
that this might be released anyway you
know in the future well we've got rules
and regulations and we won't buy those
and that's what we make our judgment on
and to simply say oh it might be thrown
into a new policy in two or three four
years time i think is quite arrogant so
i do have concerns about that
so and the other thing is it isn't loca
it is
a green belt area simple as that
the other thing is i come onto is the
flooding issue i am fully aware for
other reasons
uh of that particular river call it what
you will waterway that runs along there
all the way up to lower white barnes
film and we've had flow it's where it
backs up
so any reduction or controls at this end
will feed back and i have photographs i
can show
of housing flooding further back because
of blockages and restrictions on their
river so i'm concerned about this
flooding issue and any controls that
might be made on that river because it
will feed back
further along
okay so i i mean i have i have
photographs of this so that it does
occur so i'm concerned about this
so-called i'm not an expert but there's
flooding issue
now the other thing is that um if i
recall in one
an officer's report from previous there
was this uh letter or comments were made
by the medical profession that they this
would they would be unable to
supply an infrastructure for this
support for this this scare home i'm
sure that's what it said
so i'm concerned that
if there was a care home put there
the local people are having trouble at
the moment getting doctor's appointments
and so on and any further stress or
strain put on this system within this
area would affect a greater population
of railing for a lot of number of
reasons and i just feel that this is the
most inappropriate application and i
cannot support it and i would support
the
recommendation of refusal thank you very
much do you want to come back with
anything
katie um i don't think that
particularly anything that you were
asking a question of the only thing that
i would just point out with the in terms
of the flooding is i from my
understanding of it anyway is that there
wasn't going to be the construction of
anything to kind of divert the river so
that there wasn't going to be anything
um kind of put into the into the stream
it was that there was going to be a
bridge over it so then the water would
flow still underneath it and that's my
understanding of it
[Music]
you showed on the plane of another lake
and it gave me the impression that there
was going to be controls here otherwise
what is that so i'm concerned about that
thank you
councillor mrs mason
before i go into my five minutes can i
ask a question in the offices please
um if we could go back to the flood um
picture diagram where it showed no not
that one look that's the sus
the actual um where it showed the river
that's it that's the one thank you
surface water
right um
that's water or flood zone that's the
one surface water of course
thank you in the the offices um has
stated that the suds uh that the design
and layout is indicative
therefore logically the
suds proposal is also indicative
so i just wanted confirmation on that
the other
thing that concerns me is although it's
only indicative
that
blue blood stone going through the site
is shown to have properties on it the
intention is to property and i just
wanted that
if i've read that correctly
yeah so that is correct so the sub
scheme put forward is only indicative
they've estimated i think that the
um site would be covered by 40 hard
standing so that's what they're working
out the basis on but where if an
application say this application were
approved and a reserve manager
application were to come forward then
that would be dealt with at that stage
as well so that we could make sure that
the suds scheme was adequate to whatever
level of hardstanding was put forward
yeah thank you
thank you that was the only actual
question i have um
i i'm concerned with this in india
application i am concerned about
the lack of
information the fact that it has taken a
considerable time to get some of the
information that's been requested
um
if councillor milne is comfortable with
this i'd like to move for refusal
on the
grounds
especially with these such developments
should not be approved
except in very special circumstances
and i think there's no very special
circumstances that have been
demonstrated but in accordance with the
items already put for refusal by the
officers which i think is a very
comprehensive and full report i must
admit it confused me it spent me ages to
read it
the also
i'm concerned about the tpo the aspect
of that so
that is in the refusal the other thing i
think council lawman actually
um queried the bus and i realized that
that it comes under essex county council
but i don't see any reason why we
couldn't go back
although we're refusing it go back to
essex county council for very further
clarification regarding the point of the
bus route that he's raised so that would
be for clarification
um
for any
future
application
and
so therefore that's why i'd like it
included in the refusal at this point in
time the lack of information basically
i can see iran
on the bus stop yes the the fact that
that hasn't been covered by six county
council means that we haven't got that
information
so
although it's not within our remit to
actually refuse on that we can refuse
without the information as i understand
it i'm sure the solicitor will advise me
if i can't
we're just having our officers discuss
phoebe
as part of the application essex county
council were obviously consulted and
they raised no objection and they did
have consideration to the relocation of
the bus stop prior to the submission of
the application the applicant did speak
with them and negotiate about whether
the best location was and that was in
consultation with the highway authority
they decided that was the best location
and they did also um recommended
condition to be included if the
application were to be approved so if it
had been
approved then that condition would be on
and those details would be um for the
higher authority to agree as part of
that
okay well i'm sure councillor norman
will be happy with that and if he is i
am so therefore uh move forward
on the grounds that i've outlined if
that's um if i have a seconder
right we've got two here councillor mill
i'll do council email because she's all
counsellor
right so we're now talking
sorry
can we just clarify that the reason for
refusal is as per the officer's report
and you're satisfied that the bus stop
would be dealt with
in a previous yes as for the obvious
report on the
items the three items that are
outstanding because it wouldn't be
reasonable for us to add in a reason for
refusal on the bus stop because the
highway authority have already we've
already accepted that yeah okay i just
wanted to clarify
what we were actually going to be voting
on with your money no it's on the the
final three
very comprehensive
items for refusal thank you thank you
very much for clarifying that thank you
and i would say
with an emphasis on the fact that
there's no um very special circumstances
i would like that emphasised
does anyone want to speak about the
motion only about refusal on the three
items we've got
and that is all we'll be speaking about
are talking about now
so
yeah i know but unfortunately when
emotions on we have to then go for that
i'm sorry councillor foster um so we've
got councillor stanley do you want to
speak up
for the motion that's been put forward
for refusal
thank you chairman um
i do think that uh
the the motion has included
the uh flood alleviation
am i right
no no because that you've said that
they've said suds
i thought we was no it's on what you've
got is you've had the reasons for
refusal
uh as from the um
from the officer's report
yeah as the
officers
report yes
so it's noise impact
was asked for the
oakland
and the green belt that's what the
refusal is on
that's the three items
okay
is there a possibility to amend that
no you've just been advised we can't
we've got uh they've just clarified for
mrs mason sorry council mrs mason that
that is what we're voting on
is the refusal
for the three items
and we can't put another
i thought we could have made that to to
add two so the
suds matter has already been addressed
they've submitted details which the lead
local flood authority are content with
so we couldn't
they've now withdrawn their holding
objection
and we couldn't therefore have a reason
for refusal based on surface water i'm
sorry i thought they i thought they were
still holding on that because of where
the flood alleviation is going and it's
at the yeah it's
not where it's not where it's holding
water it will take water out of the
stream and put it into those areas the
attenuation and also the pond it is no
good putting a pond where a lake is
already it will only flood in there and
the water from the site will not go into
the council stanley we can't discuss it
no i don't know
and we've had it seconded and that's
what we've got to discuss now councillor
belton
thank you
um
this council has a policy to build on
brownfield first um other than in
exception exceptional circumstances and
the exceptional circumstances stated
here
are regarding um
property for older people such as the
care home we already have a care home
being built in rayleigh at the moment we
don't know what the uptake on that care
home will be and i can't see at all that
this is an extenuating
circumstance and i would not support
building on the green belt as a result
of that thank you thank you very much
members
council mrs mason i was going to close
this so we could have actually have a
vote
as the proposal i'm usually allowed to
say okay thank you sorry
i just wanted to clarify why i didn't
include the subs
because there does seem to be some
confusion over that um i asked the
officer who confirmed that the suds is
indicative as is the layout so therefore
that
if this ever comes back to us
it will then be decided because at the
moment we're not determining that aspect
of the application as i understand it
yes so that is
partially correct so we're saying in
principle there is a scheme on the site
that would be able to address the
surface water with the
uh potential level of hard standing that
would come forward if at the moment that
is based on a 40
coverage of the hard standing if an
application were to come forward which
covered any more than that then they
would have to update this their sud
scheme to reflect that as well
thank you thank you all right members we
have a motion on the table and it has
been seconded for refusal can i have a
show of hands please for refusal of this
application
members that is unanimous this
application has been refused thank you
members
i think we'll wait members until the
members of the public leave and then
we'll go on to item seven
if we can move a bit quickly please
see you later
that's what i dive with is my dive buddy
agenda item seven 22 stroke zero zero
five six seven full airport business
park cherry altered white and claire
buckley will present the office's report
sorry that's all right no take your time
this application is for a proposed
commercial unit under use class b8 which
is a storage use with ancillary office
space together with parking landscaping
other associated works
as you can see from this first location
plan here the site comprises an
undeveloped clock within the wider
business park site so here's the site
located here
the wider site is located to the east of
cherry orchard way
with aviation way and commercial units
to the south
wesley rugby club and some resident
runnings to the north and openland to
the east
the second location plan here gives
context of the application site within
the wider airport business park so the
site is broadly rectangular in shape but
follows the curve of the access route
the wider site is being developed on a
plot by plot basis and currently
comprises of the completed road as you
can see here we've got some landscape
infrastructure and we've got the peco
phase one unit
we've also got costa coffee over here
the launch pad site here and also some
12 industrial units here as well
the proposal is for a storage building
for use by the company camera
camera is a family-run company currently
based in dagenham docks london that uses
digitally managed sustainable storage
they safely remove and store props
costumes equipment documents and
artifacts that clients want to keep or
dispose of commonly working with film
and tv production companies
the building comprises a large ground
floor mostly for storage but also with a
lobby area and a small mezzanine level
so you can see this is the main building
here and the main warehouse area and
then this is a very small section here
which would be the lobby with mezzanine
the mezzanine would be used as an office
with storage above access will be to the
west where there's a large service yard
proposed and two entrances for hdbs so
here we can see the service yard and
here is the two hdv entrances here this
is the main access in
and to the south and south west is
imposed parking refuse storage and most
of the soft landscaping so here you can
see this is where most of the parking is
located along here and you've got some
disabled bays here this is the zoom in a
little bit this is the refuse store
so this is the refuse store here um as
well
so this plan here shows the northern and
eastern elevations and shows the
intended use of different cutting types
with grey variations a green color
coloring would be used to generate some
color interest the building would
measure 16.1 meters high to the ridge
moving to clan five so this shows um how
the building would appear from the front
western elevation and the south so here
we see the use of more glaze integrated
feature at the corner of the building
and to provide light to the lobby and
office spaces and the two huv loading
doors so you can see those here as well
and then so this would be the corner
section here and where the lobby and
office area would be located
so this section drawing um shows a
section through the building with the
warehouse visible and the mezzanine area
shown to the southwestern corner as well
so again that just shows where that
mezzanine section as well there
the key material planning considerations
are the principle of development
economic benefits highways design layout
and appearance landscaping flooding and
surface water drainage brian ecology and
air quality so looking at the principle
of development a previous application at
this site in 2001 was approved to vary
the 2015 outline application for the
wider airport business park site to
enable 10 000 meters squared of b8 use
to be provided versus the 1 000 meter
squared previously approved in 2015.
whilst this current application
represents an application application in
its own right independent of the outline
application the 2015 and subsequent 2021
applications referred to which approved
a greater quantum of ba use are material
to the current application and confirm
the approach previously considered
acceptable by the council
this approach was subject to
consultation and had the support of the
council's strategic policy and economic
development team and still does
the proposal alongside other flexible
use permissions already granted would
result in a ten thousand meter squared
figure being exceeded by 301 meters
squared but this is considered to be
marginal
there is no objection to the principle
of the development here
looking at economic benefits the
submitted economic benefits statement
advises that the proposal would generate
around 55 000 pounds in business rates
revenue per annum for rochford and
promote job creation this represents new
inward investment into the district
in looking at highways the proposed
development will provide 23 car parking
spaces including two accessible spaces
and three motorbike parking spaces this
is marginally in excess of maximum
parking standards
the parking bay sizes are proposed to be
2.5 meters wide by 5 meter long as per
other plots on the edge airport business
park
the development will also provide 16
cycle parking spaces
the transport assessment confirms that
the proposal is not expected to have a
significant impact upon the local
transport network and a draft travel
plan has been produced
looking at design layout and appearance
the design approach is consistent with
that which has been previously consented
across the business park and
incorporates the use of high quality and
contemporary materials such as grey
metal sheet cladding the urban design
consultant advises that it is broadly in
line with the design code for this plot
and raises no objection
looking at landscaping the soft
landscape proposed is predominantly
around the perimeter and includes new
tree planting new grass areas ornamental
shrub planting hedge planting and a
native buffer mix hard landscape scan
card landscaping includes concrete hard
standing within the service yard and
permeable block paving to the parking
bays
a 2.4 meter high perimeter metal fence
would be proposed as boundary treatment
the landscaping will pose is considered
acceptable
looking at flooding and surface water
drainage the site is located within
flood zone one
storage would be provided in geocellular
storage parallel paving and filter
drains where appropriate and would link
to the wide to site-wide sub-system
the lead local flood authority has no
objection to the proposed development
subject to the conditions attached as
part of the officer's recommendation
and then looking at briam a brand
pre-assessment details that the scheme
will achieve a rating of very good and
attainment level of very good is
considered acceptable here and is in
accordance with policy
moving on to ecology the preliminary
collateral appraisal submitted concludes
that the overall impact of the proposal
is considered to be neutral
and then air quality finally the air
quality assessment submitted has a
requirement for measures around dust
emissions during construction this
requires inspection logs to be available
to the council when requested
this application is recommended for
approval subject to the conditions
outlined in the offices report
thank you very much
we have one speaker on this it's mr
nick
dimmitt
and i always get your name wrong i do
apologize so we've got the uh table
there again you know the form we've got
five minutes and then one i'll let you
know when there's one minute to go
thank you do i is it do i switch no it's
already it's already on it's already on
here you can move it up or near you if
you need to
okay
great thank you chair my name is nick
diamond and i'm hbd's planning agent
as set out in your office's report this
application it seeks full planning
permission for a commercial unit
to be operated by camera and is
recommended for approval
camera leads the way in providing
digitally managed sustainable storage to
a wide range of corporate clients
including film and television industry
they also provide an online platform and
marketplace for productions to manage
store sell or do donate their assets
this represents a real contribution to
the circular economy
and the benefits of which have been
recognized by the chair of the thames
estuary growth board
camera's decision to relocate from
dagenham
docks to rochford represents further
inward investment for the district and
in so doing supports your economic
growth strategy
the economic benefit statement submitted
alongside the application
concluded that the proposal would
support 37 on-site full-time employees
in addition to circa 83 jobs during
construction
both your planning and economic
development officers agree that the
proposal complies with the strategic
aims of the district's planning and
economic development policies
the unit will be of high quality
specification and complement the
surrounding built form including ipeco
to the east and the innovation hub to
the north
signage and active frontages are to be
provided on the southeastern corner to
break up the massing and improve
legibility
the accompanying transport statement
considered vehicle movements including
hdvs
when we presented recently two members
hdv's in the context of the airport
business park were raised
the proposal will have a minimum impact
on the highway network and the small
proportion of hdv movements
approximately 34 two-way daily and only
one to two trips in the peak can be
comfortably accommodated on the network
in conclusion the proposal before you
accords with the aspirations of the [ __ ]
will further complement the offering of
the airport business park and deliver
economic benefits and employment
opportunities to the district
we therefore ask that you follow your
officer recommendation and approve this
application
thank you
thank you
we have one award member here is
councillor williams
again councillor williams you have five
minutes
thank you chairman yeah i i thoroughly
welcome
this proposal and in fact i would like
to propose now that we accept this
thank you
has anyone got have you got a secondary
yeah well we've got a hands at council
foster it's the first up okay so we have
a motion on the table
to speak for
acceptance and he said
yes sorry it's acceptance approval sorry
um so councillor stanley would you like
to speak
promotion thank you chairman um two well
there are three things i'd like to ask
the officers
um uh is there anywhere on the site for
fauna and flora
area
and also
how many electric charging vehicle
points are there and how many disabled
parking bays are there please uh
councillor stanley 7.6 2.5 that will
give you all the details you need to
know on the parking and the charging
disabled etcetera
and now i beg your pardon that's not a
problem i don't know where the fauna and
flora are but i know that is because
i've just been reading it i didn't hear
anything on that no but
also
sorry my watch is talking it isn't going
to understand what you said sorry
um
no that wasn't but it is in that's why
we had the report to read before it we
come to committee so is it in there i
will do apologize members i'll put my
watch away he didn't understand what
councillor stanley was saying sorry um
uh
fauna
so there is soft landscaping um it's
mostly going to be so you've got a small
section to
present
no no doesn't it um to the north there
but also then the predominant amount
would be along these sections along the
frontage here and then curving back
round
to this area along here
this is where the majority of the soft
landscape would be so surrounding the
parking bays
it's got strategic i mean the actual
wider site has a whole past of strategic
um
landscaping outside of this main red
line site boundary but the wider actual
business park site has strategic
landscaping running through it so you
see this section here that's a strategic
landscape area there as well but the
actual site itself will have an element
of soft landscaping itself and we have
we have details of that and we can
control that by condition as well in
terms of the needing to comply with what
they've given us in terms of detail
thank you all i'm asking is that we we
put we put in what is natural to the
area in the way of trees or shrubs and
that sort of thing so
i'd like to make that
clear that's what we need to do thank
you
i think what they've actually provided
us with is a mixture of some ornamental
some um native buffer mix so there will
definitely be an element of native there
mixed in with some ornamental as well
just to sort of give a bit of a
differing of appearance so taking on a
bit of a blend of the two lovely thank
you
thank you
members is there anyone else would like
to speak with councillor mrs mason
i'm sure we've all read this report
but it's necessarily these reports are
lengthy and complex
and we don't necessarily recall
everything in them so
do forgive me if i ask a question that's
um
in the report
um
i see no uh indication of any photo
vocalic panels or solar panels
has that been considered in this
application because with such a large
expansive roof it would be a shame
if that opportunity wasn't um
taken advantage of shall we say
especially in the light of the present
situation
so
i may ask that question and i have read
the report
no there isn't reference within the
report to it and we don't have a
condition controlling that at the
present time within the office report as
would it be um possible would counselor
uh
aside but one small point aside i would
say it's very good to see an application
that benefits both the community and his
policy compliance
so i would certainly
support
approval
would you like to come back on that
we're just i think currently just
researching our policy requirement for
the 10 renewable that we often do attach
to applications what sizing of floor
space it is required for commercial
because there is a certain requirement
in terms of how we apply policy isn't
there would you like to uh
hear what councilor williams is saying
why you're looking in the house okay
council williams thank you chairman i
was just going to say that thank you
counselor
mrs mason um yeah i would be more than
happy to have a condition that any
renewable energy
should be considered
and that's all really i don't think we
can insist on it but yeah it should be
considered a recommendation there's a
recommendation
just let our officers
all right
can you you sorry can you guess what
people need to hear thank you
that's right no problem
hello
um thank you chair um just for
clarification how many hgvs were
going to be using the site per day i
missed it
29 a day
okay
thank you thank you
right i think we've got an answer for
councillor mrs mason and councillor
williams
perhaps we have um
yes so our policy requires um or allows
us to apply the 10 renewable if it's
more than a thousand meters squared we
just needed to double check what the
figure was and that does exceed it in
this case so
we can impose that condition if you
consider it you can do it as a condition
yes we can add that as a condition
excellent
would you like to
certainly go with that thank you so you
want the condition for solar panels or
renewable energy if it's possible to do
so yes please
renewable energy that makes more sense
in solar panels because things move
along
as the council built so most body would
tell me
are we okay
yeah are we okay with that officers can
we go to the vote
are you all right thank you members we
have a motion on the table for
acceptance approval
and i have a show of hands
in favor of this application
that members is unanimous thank you
hi tomate
it's 21 strokes zero zero six seven
three full rainbow's end beaches road
roareth
katie
fowler you'll be the officer yes yes
thank you chairman
the application site is located on the
northern side of beaches road the sites
are joined by the river crouch to the
north and beaches road to the south so
if we're just looking at the plan on the
screen the application site is outlined
in red here and then the larger blue
area reaches up to the crouch at the top
and then beaches road
to the south here
the site is adjacent to the businesses
drake trees and wildflower travelling
tea party which are located to the west
the application site is located towards
the junction of beaches road and
chelmsford road to the east of the site
the street comes immediately more rural
in character by comprising open fields
which are absent of built form the
applicant has lived on the site within
the mobile home since temporary
permission was granted for the
agricultural occupancy in 2019 and in a
previous mobile home on the site since
june 2016
planning mission is sought for the
proposed use of land for the station of
two mobile homes to be used by the
applicant and his daughter as a roman
egyptian family
one of the mobile homes is the existing
mobile home on the site that was
prevented in 2019 and this would be
retained an additional mobile home would
be brought onto the site and positioned
along the southern boundary it is
understood that the door has also moved
onto the site and the application is
retrospective
we're just looking at the plan this is
the existing mobile home here and this
is where the proposed new mobile home
would be cited
the applicant claims gypsy and traveller
status the applicant has provided a
personal statement which discusses his
nomadic lifestyle which he and his
parents led growing up this involved
moving around to work on farms and
trading horses during the touring season
the family eventually moved to essex to
conduct farm work the applicant has also
provided details of work that he has
undertaken as a third person
representing the traveling community the
applicant has stated in their personal
statement that he is now of an age where
he feels he should settle and care for
his daughter who has mental health
issues
on a balance of probabilities the
applicant has been considered to meet
the definition set out in the planning
policy for traveller sites
the principal consideration in the
application is the impact of the
development upon the green bill the
policies relating to this are laid out
within the office's report
the proposal would introduce two
permanent mobile homes on what was
essentially an undeveloped field the
proposal for residential development
would be considered to constitute urban
spoil within the greenville equating to
inappropriate development that is
harmful by definition the development
must therefore demonstrate that there
are very special circumstances which
outweigh the harm to the green belt
policy h7 of the core strategy felt to
allocate 15 pitches by 2018 and this was
reflected through the allocation of gt1
at michelin's farm due to various
complications and difficulties
development of this site has yet to
commence and the council have not
exercised its power to compulsory
purchase there are no other available
allocated or public sites available for
occupation within the district and
therefore the council's requirement to
deliver gypsy and traveller pitches must
be accommodated elsewhere
further to this the latest formal
assessment of the district's need
identified the need of up to 18
additional pitches for households
meeting the ppts definition of a
traveler with a further three pitches
for households where it is unknown
whether the definition is met
there has been the recent granting of
planning permission for five pitches and
therefore the remain there remains a
need for at least 13 pitches dedicated
to households meeting this definition
as such the council are unable to
demonstrate a five-year supply of sites
for gypsy and travellers and this should
be given significant weight in the
greenbelt balance in addition the lack
of alternative provision should also be
attached significant weight
the applicant states within the human
rights questionnaire that there are no
available pitches with family members
locally and they are unable to stay on
any mixed communal or council site as it
is as it is traditional for roman
egyptians to travel and stay in small
family groups the applicant has pointed
out that whilst roman egyptians and
irish travelers are affected by the same
problems of accessing services
accommodation health issues
are still quite they are still quite
different in several cultural practices
these cultural differences can lead to
issues on site and the applicant does
not feel that at his age and with his
daughter's health issues that they would
be equipped for the confrontational
situations that occur on shared public
sites due to the differences between
cultural transient groups
the proposed mobile homes would serve
the applicant and his adult daughter due
to cultural traditions it would be
inappropriate for the applicant to share
a mobile home with his daughter and this
leads to the requirement for the second
mobile home
the applicant's daughter suffers from
mental health issues and a letter from
her psychiatrist confirms that there are
concerns over her living independently
and the applicant is providing regular
support in the interest of her health
and wellbeing the applicant is required
to stay locally due to being responsible
for caring for his three grandchildren
three days a week and so that his
daughter has access to her registered
doctors
therefore while substantial weight is
given to her to the harm to the
greenbelt significant weight is also
attached to the need for gypsy and
traveler sites the lack of supply of
sites particularly the uncertainty in
bringing forward the only allocated site
the absence of local policy and the lack
of available alternative accommodation
for the applicant and his daughter with
accessibility to health services
in this case there are a number of
matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of recent
appeal decisions subsequently the
cumulative weight of these very special
circumstances would clearly outweigh the
substantial harm arising from the
inappropriate development in the green
belt
in terms of the impact of the
development upon other considerations
there have been no reports of the
residential development causing noise or
disturbance given the substantial
distance to any nearby residential
properties the site would be accessed
through an existing access on beaches
road and would not cause conflict with
highway safety as a mobile home is
existing it is understood there is an
existing septic tank on site that both
mobile homes would utilize for foul
drainage
there are no trees of significance
located on the site however the hedgerow
along the southern boundary offers a
degree of amenity and screening to
understand the landscape vision on site
a condition has been recommended to
outline the soft and hard landscaping
the application site is located in flood
zone 3 and as a mobile home the use
would fall within the category of highly
vulnerable development in the first
instance the government development must
pass a sequential test given the
cultural requirements of the applicants
the proposal requires a real location
which forces the green belt in which
there are no available or affordable
alternative sites within the district
however as a highly vulnerable
development the ppg indicates that this
type of development should not be
permitted in flood zone 3 and the ea
have objected to the application on this
basis
nonetheless temporary plan permission
for the sighting of a mobile home has
been granted on the site and this does
not expire until october 2022 within
this application it was concluded that
as the council's emergency plan accepted
the flood risk to the occupants and that
the proposed risk was able to be managed
through the flood response plan the
flood risk was acceptable the proposed
development would involve the addition
of one mobile home and that would be
used by the same family unit as such it
is not considered to have a greater
material blood risk on the site
whilst this would not be the usual
approach taken to such an application as
permission has been granted during this
conclusion it would be unreasonable for
the council to refuse an application now
on site where the development had
already been considered acceptable in
the flood zone given that there would
not be a net increase of family units
subsequently the application is
recommended for approval chairman
subject to the conditions set out in the
report thank you thank you very much
we've got no public public speakers on
this the uh wall councillors are
counselor crips and councillor stanley
do either of you would like to speak
well do both of you want to speak on
this
that's the crits this is the crips
yeah the game counts to chris got five
minutes thank you
thank you madam chairman
i'd like to cut straight to the
conclusion paragraph 6.1
it's quite brief just one paragraph
however the officer's report and the
conclusion make it clear that the
decisive issue here
is the non-provision of the 15 pitch
allocation via the local plan
we are now four years beyond the
delivery deadline and so i've seen a
series of applications all of which were
cited in the offices report
as president
the most worrying thing to come out of
an appeal decision on one of those
was the inspector's view that he sees no
indication of a policy solution coming
forward in a foreseeable future
so
i cannot in all honestly disagree with
the officer's conclusion because they
have no other option
but equally i cannot vote for a default
policy which continues to use the green
belt as a solution
thank you thank you very much carlos
stanley thank you chairman
um first firstly
my ask the
officers does this
new caravan
that's to be that is on site and should
has not got permission to go on site
until we say so
does this constitute
a part of the
travellers
units that we have to supply
also
the
shed that is there
is that to be demolished and taken away
permanently or is another shed going to
be put in its place or place off in a
place of
the
although the applicant
is
is there
it would seem that obviously
it doesn't say where the applicant or
where their daughter was before
moving in with her father
there's obviously some sort of deviation
there somewhere
uh
with this application i don't understand
that part
um also
um the recommendations or the conditions
that you put in for
green
green rounded or hedging or something
like that
it looks to be in two different places
so
is that is that going to be
continued on both sides
because that is i know it's one side but
it's both pitches do we consider them to
be two pitches
i don't really see
although recommendation by the officers
is that we should accept it but again
this is on greenbelt land
and
i don't really see special concern
circumstances in that respect of
what he said as mental health here
although the doctor has said it's mental
health that and she requires
constant
uh looking after
um that goes for a lot of circumstances
where we are having or parents are
having to have their children at home
because of that circumstances
and to put another caravan up i i don't
see that as a special circumstance at
all
nevertheless
um with that recommendation what the
officers have said
i'll go with
thank you thank you
councillor constable
yes
against the application on the basis of
the sighting of the caravan on beaches
road as all of us that use that road
that can be a very fast and very busy
road at times and they're sighting a
caravan right next to the road which is
going to stand out like a sore thumb
i'm against the application on the bases
where the caravan is going to be sighted
as is next to the road if the daughter
has mental health issues sighting a
caravan next to a very busy road i can't
see that being very good for her health
and on the basis of where the caravan is
cited i'm against that proposal
and i'd like to move a motion on that
basis
are you a second term
so would you like to come back officers
um so they as councillor stanley pointed
out there is a condition relating to
landscaping so at the moment there is
some hedging along the road which does
act as screening and that condition acts
to control that so that we are able to
maintain a degree of screening
and to try and lessen the impact of the
development upon the public realm yeah
but a mobile caravan by its very
definition
is three meters in height and the mobile
caravan once it's off the ground is
another
for two foot off the ground so the
hedging would have to be three or four
meters high to screen the caravan
and that's the base my base is on
being against that proposal it's purely
on the position of the sighting of the
caravan
this is going to come back
so it's our understanding that the dense
hedgerow there does
screen the impact
thoroughly enough
um to an extent that it doesn't harm the
street scene or when viewed from the
highway um
in relation to the impact on the wider
area
it's still a caravan parked next to the
main road
and you know
that that's my opinion anyway
so sorry my apologies i've been to the
site recently and it's not until you
actually get onto the site that you can
actually really see the caravan
that's actually alongside the hedgerow
that's there's a dense hedgerow on
beaches road
you've got
some stable buildings and then you've
got one mobile caravan which is the
proposed new one and then there's the
existing one deeper into the site
although that that plan there shows that
it's butted right up against the
boundary on that boundary is a dense
hedgerow
so it's not that you're driving past the
site and immediately seeing
the caravan
right but it's still a noise
in my opinion it's a noise aspect for
the owners and as it's been stated she
has mental wealth issues
i just a little bit concerned about the
position of the caravan okay so
so the application is obviously for the
use of the land for station in the
caravan what we could do
is ask for a
layout plan to be submitted that shows
how the site will be laid out
notwithstanding what's
submitted on this application
my only concern is is that
if he was to put forward a motion
for refusing the application based on
the location of the caravan and its
impact on the mental health of the
daughter
the daughter i believe actually lives in
will be living in the caravan that's
further into the site that's my
understanding
my understanding is not
what is it
only because this is the existing one
and that is where the applicant was
living and this is the proposed new one
um that was brought onto the site
but i haven't visited it recently so the
play equipment the child's play
equipment is all around the
um
caravan that's deeper into the site if
if the caravan was sited in a different
position away from the main road then
obviously that would address my concerns
but my concerns are
is you know the size of a mobile caravan
is quite large i know you say
it's not that visible but
like you say she's got mental health
issues and that's my concern
so
can i
you're saying you could ask for a new
site plan better site plan could we then
defer this item until you get that i'm
gonna shake of the head no
we could condition it
well you could condition it
but you get a better site plan
no it would be an alternative site plan
so that they could revise the layout and
show an alternative positioning of the
mobile home that's currently a long
beaches road because we've got a member
saying that he will not support this
because of the site plan we've got so
far
and i'm very concerned that we're going
to vote on something that we could
actually then ask for another
well we can't i'm just confused please
yeah we can condition
um
an approval because what we're approving
here what's before committee is the
change you use the land for the sighting
of the caravan
so we could put a condition on that
requires the applicant to submit a
layout plan
that shows exactly how the site is going
to be laid out
and what they could do on that layout
plan is showing more detail the
um the depth of the existing hedgerow
and how it's not abutted right up
against the boundary which is indicated
here i mean it's not particularly
helpful that plan
and then that
we can then assess that
and then take a view as to whether or
not
we consider that to be acceptable or not
yeah
well i've got at the moment i've got
council foster councillor mason council
estate agency and council williams wants
to speak to councillor foster
chairman
um i've got two questions um on
point 1.1 page 8.2 paragraph 3.
it talks about when mr barry taylor
moves or ceases to occupy
the land gets cleared so my question is
twofold really one is when he
ceases to occupy for whatever reason
does that force his daughter out if
let's say he died for the sake of
argument
does that force his daughter out and if
so to where and secondly if that does
happen and the land has to be cleared
who pays for it
thank you
so the condition currently reads that
the use is permitted to mr barry taylor
and his dependent um but then goes on to
say that when the land ceases to be
occupied by mr barry taylor and doesn't
specify the dependent but what we could
do is amend it to include and his
dependents so that if for example if he
passed away then the dependent could
carry on to live there okay thank you
and part two of the question sorry could
you repeat that part if at some point it
does happen that has to be cleared who
pays
that would be for the applicant to pay
all the dependent
okay thank you
council mr payson
thank you chair i think we all have
some concerns on this
um
councillor foster's question
addressed one of my concerns but i still
would like to ask another
question regarding the personal
circumstances
personal circumstances per se obviously
um
but this is a personal
um occupation a grant of occupation and
i haven't seen forgive me if i've missed
it i haven't seen any time span on that
um would it be possible to perhaps put a
say a five-year time span on that so
that if circumstances change
then we can readdress this
and i also
note the comments by the counsellors
about the location on site and that it
can be determined
whether it's susceptible with a site
plan but
we're trying to make a decision here in
the committee that
puts the decision back to the offices
which does leave some element of concern
with all respect to the officers because
the decision-making body should be here
this is a personal
permission for the applicant and i think
we can we all have great sympathy
but regardless of the other reasons for
determination of this retrospective
application it is just so regrettable
that we have to judge this against the
failure of this council to implement its
core strategy that was adopted in 2011.
and i'll leave it there thank you
thank you council stanley
thank you
i'm still waiting for an answer on the
questions that i asked
sorry i thought you'd actually receive
them no i haven't no sorry i do
apologize sorry i thought you had sorry
cuts instead
yeah yeah thank you three to two yeah um
so
uh
so in terms of the pitches the new
caravan because they form one family
unit it just forms one pitch it's not
two separate pitches
um so it would be
one single pitch
um and i'm not aware of a shed on the
site so i'm not sure about whether it
would be demolished as part of the
application because it hasn't been it
hasn't formed part of the application
but it would you could be something that
you could raise with the enforcement
team to cover that
only the
the shed is supposed to i believe that
the shed is
either very close or on that corner as
well
which we are talking about and it's
replacing the caravan we'll replace the
shed basically so where is the shed
going to go
because we're gonna have three buildings
on there
and and we've
we're sort of saying have two i mean i
don't see any reason why the shed the
caravan has to be placed on that corner
why can't it go adjacent to or alongside
the original
caravan i don't see any reason why that
and then that would cure all of our
problems
and as it is one site
uh i'm very
skeptical of of how many more people in
the family are going to have a caravan
on the site to make it one site
so can a condition be made
towards that
in that
no other caravans
for anyone to go on that site unless it
is we are going to make it a pitch site
please
so can i just state the member of the
public we cannot take any um
questions no sorry we cannot um sorry
thank you
just to assist members um
so they understand how the site is set
out at the moment um along here there
are some
uh out buildings that um it's understood
that they're used for
um the equestrian use on the site
there's some
some
ponies or horses on the site and then
you've got like a paddock area here and
then on the other side of the paddock
area is the building so it's not like
this is like a
a vast open space
this pack plan isn't particularly
helpful appreciate that for members but
as i say um there's buildings along here
uh paddock area in the middle there and
then you've got
you've got the site and there's a track
that runs up to
um the agricultural buildings that are
at the top here i don't know if that
system
but as i say as as mentioned previously
we can ask for a more detailed layout
plan
the reason that i'm i'm concerned with
it is the fact that
the both units have a waste
to go to both units will actually use a
cesspit if you like which is either at
the other end of the field or this end
of the field we don't know which
um
and i'm cons i'm really worried about
the
hygiene way away it's being planned at
the moment it does it looks a bit
higgledy-piggledy in as much as why
can't that unit be put alongside the
original one and you can then
then it'll be easier to to accommodate
whatever
problems there may be where it is at the
moment it's a problem because it's it's
near the
stables and and and so on and i don't
see how somebody is going to have peace
of mind if they're in a mental stage
with horses
jumping in the box and and that sort of
thing making a racket when that is not
the right place for it to be and i would
suggest if i may chairman that
the unit should be up with the other
area not with the horses or the stables
because that that would just it just
increases the problem i don't see that
as a that is the right way to go about
it that's my view anyway and i i don't
know can we make a condition to defer
this
defer this to no we've been told we
can't defer because i asked that
question um
right i did ask that if we could but
they said
um our officers said we couldn't um
we've got to vote either approval or
refusal and they will then go back and
ask for a better
plan which counselor
we can we can we can now defer it yeah
oh no we can't we were just
we were suggesting that it could be
dealt with by condition which would
obviously save the committee time and
bringing it back to committee but if
members
want that certainty then we can we can
do right so what do i do with the motion
that we had on the table for refusal
um well
we need to still answer councillor
stanley's questions because he's just
counseled mrs basin for five years i'll
vote on councillor
mrs masons
she councillor mrs mason had a query
about
putting five years on it didn't you
yeah you didn't
yeah
the other thing i'd like to bring this
up because it's confusing the officer
has just said paddocks in the report on
2.2
it says it is evident from aerial
photographs that management and i don't
know how to pronounce it
minaj has been erected between the two
mobile homes which probably explains the
sighting so and that that is uh that
hasn't got permission so
that's
possibly why we have this
difficulty over the sighting
um
and certainly i i think deferment would
be
there's too many issues here that
haven't been
adequately addressed and i know we're
all concerned about it we're also
concerned that we have someone who has a
difficult situation a personally
difficult situation and i'm sure as a
counselor we want to help them at the
same time we have policies that we
should comply by
and it's a difficult one because the
heart says yes approve it
the
logic on the council's failure says that
perhaps we shouldn't and my suggestion
would be that if we defer it then
hopefully the areas of concern that we
we're all concerned about could be
addressed and we can then approve it
right
can we
sorry
sorry um i just didn't know if i
wouldn't if miss mason wanted me to come
back on her questions
at the time yes so
um
in terms of the time span it
we haven't considered it reasonable in
this instance to imply such a condition
because in the recent appeals
uh decisions for gypsy and traveller
sites they found that it wasn't
reasonable because we have this personal
condition
which says that um
the use would cease when it's no longer
occupied by the applicant or their
dependents
that means that the use wouldn't be
necessarily a permanent
thing on that site in forever anyway so
it hasn't been determined that it would
be reasonable to impose such a condition
on other on other recent applications
that are similar and that's why we
haven't sought that in this instance
i thought because the reasoning was for
one and mental health that that was
hopefully not an optimistically not a
long-term situation but i'd refer to the
officer's experience on that
members
my motion which was seconded yeah that's
what i was trying to establish before
everyone you know everyone i was trying
to give everyone a chance to speak and
now we've had another one to say we'd
like to defer it so
i'm gonna i'm really sorry council
council i have not got a clue
which way we've got to go on this first
what votes i have seen your council
norman but we look at i'm trying to find
out the correct procedure well
if that it would help i'm happy to
change my motion to defer in it subject
to a another site plan with a different
arrangement for the caravans if that's
more comprehensive site plan yes and and
well
better sighting
yeah recite the caravan before it comes
back different plans showing this
caravan in a different position okay so
we've got a new
yeah we could do that and
councilman did you i'll second that
right okay members
can we go for this motion
thank you i mean obviously the
situation's changed since i put my hand
up but i can support a deferment because
ultimately the people are already living
on this site so it's not going to change
their circumstance in the short term
it's not an urgent application in that
sense i think that's sensible
um i don't know that we should be
saying they have to change the sighting
of the the um caravan because i think we
need to see the site location plan first
because bold intents and purposes that
looks like an old plan that's
potentially not the greatest and it
doesn't show the other outbuildings and
so on but ultimately what we're supposed
to be deciding if i understand it is
that we're happy for another dwelling to
be within that site and occupied not
necessarily the specific site but i
think given the circumstance deferment
makes sense just to cover peace of mind
and i'd support that
thank you chairman
um ultimately as a council we found to
me our obligation of supplying
sufficient gypsy and traveller sites um
therefore in this case i cannot possibly
um
support a refusal i could possibly
refute accep
support
defer
being deferral at this time but
certainly not a refusal yeah the motion
is for deferral not refusal now uh
council government we are talking on
deferral
german
he's got a life of its own
determine i've got no issue with that
it's just i was going to suggest
something separate but um i'm happy with
the deferment okay members so we have a
motion on the table and it's been
seconded for deferral
of this application
and
officers are you are okay with what we
are deferring it on
yeah yes so we're gonna
yeah by saying for the reasons why we
def we want it to fire so we're going to
go back to the
applicant and
obviously relay the information that's
come from the committee
that there's concerns about the site in
the caravan alongside beaches road and
ask them to submit a revised site layout
to bring back to committee yes perhaps
if we can have in future but ask the
applicants to give us a better site plan
which would help us a great deal without
having to go around this
um as well it would be a lot helpful
right members can we have a show of
hands
for
approval for deferral
please show off hands please
against members
so that has been carried
for for deferral
to against
thank you members
ten ten ten ten four
two ten four
two against ten four yeah
stop it mister stop it uh counselor
stanley my watch is confused you've
confused my watch automatically
thank you members
item agenda nine stroke uh
one
twenty two stroke troubles
zero three seven one four land opposite
brick layers arms tenders avenue
rayleigh
um katy fowler will present the
officer's report over to you katie
please
claire
oh i've got no it's right it's on my
nose it says katie fowler
sorry
please
so this application is to demolish the
existing dilapidated stables
sorry
demolish existing dilapidated stables
subdivide the plot into three and
construct a one-bedroom new build
bungalow with access and drive onto
trenders avenue in rayleigh as you can
see from the location plan the site is
located on the eastern side of trenders
avenue and is noticeably open with the
absence of much built form with the
exception of two buildings as you can
see here and some paddock fencing to the
north of the site is open land
with some buildings located to the east
again it's open land and residential
garden to the south is goldsmith drive
and then we have a residential and
commercial site known as urquhart house
the site is located within the greenbelt
the existing buildings consist of a
square form single stable and then a
rectangular rectangular building
providing three stables without a roof
as you can see here this is the square
stable looking like this and the attack
rectangular one where and we don't
currently have the roof rusted remain
but the majority of the roof
has gone over time
just to show you a photo this is just
what the site looks like at the moment
as you see that's that square building
the rectangular one here as well
the proposal would demolish these
building construct an l-shaped bungalow
in approximately the same position as
these buildings there will be a new
vehicle across over and driveway into
the site with parking area and garden so
as you can see here this is where the
actual bungalow would be located you can
just about see and i can zoom in a
little bit the actual red markings of
where the existing buildings are and you
can see where the garden areas continue
to be new access and parking area here
just zoom in slightly and then you can
see
where those red lines are which actually
show
the existing building as well so those
lines here you can see the rectangular
building just about there and the red
one and the square building is sort of
hidden underneath there
so this plan shows the design of the
bungalow proposed it would be the simple
design traditional of the dwelling style
within trenders avenue with a pitched
roof and gable ends materials opposed
would include facing brick render and
horizontal black timber cladding the key
material planning considerations are
green belt impact on character
residential amenity garden size
sustainability
highway safety refuse and recycling and
trees and ecology so looking at the
greenbelt the site is located within the
greenbelt where policies exist
controlling development
the mppf sets out the construction of
new buildings is inappropriate in the
green belt unless the proposal would
fall under one of the specified
exceptions the site represents
previously developed land being
previously used as stables which
represents one of the exceptions listed
a site which is previously developed
land must also ensure the proposed
development would not have a greater
impact on the openness of the greenbelt
the site is approximately five square
meters less in floor space than the
existing buildings but does have an
average height increase of approximately
0.8 meters
the building would be cited in the same
position as the existing buildings
the height increase is minimal and
bearing in mind the reduction in floor
space it is not considered that the
proposal would have a greater impact on
openness than the existing buildings
the proposal was considered to form
appropriate development within the
greenbelt
it should be noted that this application
represents a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme in 20 2021
this previous application was only
refused due to the lack of an ecological
survey it was not refused for greenbelt
reasoning looking at impact on character
the simple design is traditional for
other bungalows along trenders avenue
this is considered acceptable
residential amenity so the proposal
would not be considered to give rise to
overlooking overshadowing or an
overbearing impact on residential
amenity
all existing residential properties are
a reasonable distance from the proposed
dwelling
looking at garden size the garden area
proposed equates to 764 metres squared
well in excess of 100 meters squared
requirement
looking at sustainability the proposed
scheme is for a single story one bedroom
two person dwelling its sizing would
accord with the technical housing
standard requirements
then highway safety the site will
provide an area to the front of the
dwelling that will be able to provide at
least two off-street parking spaces
measuring to the preferred bay size in
accordance with the parking standards
refuse and recycling the site is
considered to provide adequate space for
the council's three-bin system
and then finally looking at trees and
ecology so the trees located on the site
are not of great significance it is
unlikely that any impact would result
from the proposal upon these trees
therefore no objection is raised there
is no evidence of the presence of bats
at the site
the application was previously refused
due to the lack of an ecological survey
particularly around great quested news
whilst there remains a lack of survey
information provided the applicant has
entered into the essex district
licensing scheme an imp and an impact
assessment and conservation payment
certificate has been provided and
counter-signed by natural england in
addition to this the need for a great
crested newt licence or other form of
mitigation has been controlled by
planning condition
as a result the previous reason for
refusal has been overcome and the
council's ecological consultant no
longer objects to the proposal
this application is recommended for
approval subject to the conditions
outlined in the officers report but also
with the inclusion of a further
condition number eight controlling the
size of the residential kurdish so this
does not appear in the office report nor
does it appear on the addendum i'm just
going to show you the description now
it's just to try and control
making sure that the cartilage is of a
reasonable size and not extending to the
whole site area
oh
sorry that's not that
so this is the condition wording we're
proposing for condition number eight so
the residential courtesy to the dwelling
hereby approved should only include the
area shown hatched and outlined in green
on the approved layout drawing number
452 at no time shall the wider
application site be used as residential
cartilage i'll just show you the plan
that we've drawn up to go alongside that
you turn it sorry
so right there with me
apparently i can't rotate don't have
permission
there we go sorry we got her eventually
right so this is the green hatching
message estimates just to avoid because
the actual overall site area is shown as
this whole dashed line here and if we
were to grant permission we want to make
sure that that whole area
is not considered to be residential
cartilage so that condition just
controls it to be the area that they've
identified actually as well but it just
gives that extra control over that so
we've identified it as a particular
condition as well
thank you katie we've got uh
the wall councillors are council crips
and council
stanley
councillor grips please
i think the added
condition number eight
covers the point i was going to raise in
boxing in the
era of the cartilage that
is protected by the condition
and it doesn't apply
to
liberating the rest of the site and i
think number eight that they've just
read out has answered one question thank
you thank you very much
cancer stanley
i failed to i'm sorry uh madam chairman
i i
i failed to respond to
any circumstances that i do know the
applicant
and
i will be abstaining on this one thank
you can that be noted please
no that's fine no that's fine we all
make mistakes or we i have oversights
council and mrs mason
thank you chicken i just asked two
questions um
i noted that
that's going to become the residential
cartilage
but um
will it still retain its green belt
status
yes the site would still be located
within the green belt
so
they couldn't build out onto the rest of
the site we've imposed a condition which
does control
extensions and outbuildings and so
removes what is the permitted
development right to be able to do that
on the site
yes okay thank you
council foster
thank you chairman
um having listened to the report and
having read it strikes me that this
removes dilapidated buildings
arguably improves the site and given the
conditions i'd move for approval thank
you have you a secondary councillor
belton
so we have a motion that to approve and
we have a secondary council of elton
members we have the
motion on the table for approval can i
please have a show of hands for approval
on this
application please
everyone excellent
so it's 11 4 and as already indicated
one abstention thank you this
application has been approved thank you
members i now close the main uh meeting
and i've got what's the time
for 904 thank you members